[Music]
last year I spoke about Python recommend
doing recommendations in Python and
especially hybrid recommendations where
you not only use collaborative filtering
signals but also also metadata
information as I was double sort of my
talk last year and I guess every other
talk at this conference and sort of
other conferences this year next year
and probably last year as well is sort
of on on neural networks and deep
learning so I thought oh I'll capitalize
on this and see how to do
recommendations using good learning so
here goes and throughout the talk if you
have any questions just just let me know
and happy to answer them okay motivation
so the rise of deep learning has given
us new and wonderful techniques and your
wonderful toolkits to do very fun stuff
and it's been incredibly successful and
image recognition has been incredibly
successful machine translation that's
amazing results in reinforcement
learning but what really is the use of
recommendations like the probably the
best recommender system you can deploy
straight away in your application is
just recommend the most popular item for
everyone it will do amazingly well and
I'll give you what get you 60% of the
way and the other two the workhorse of
the recommender systems literature are
the matrix factorization models which
are extremely simple and again work very
well so really what's the what's the
draw of deep learning was the draw near
Network toolkits for doing
recommendations so my position on this
is follows there are a bunch of a bunch
of huge advantages firstly if you're
using a neural network toolkit you get
speed of iteration you can make very you
can make changes to model very very
quickly try them out very quickly you
don't have to implement sophisticated
SGD models by hand you just change your
loss function or you change your
representation and the neural network
that you're using it takes care of the
backpropagation for you so that's really
useful another advantage is flexibility
so if you're using existing packages for
accommodations like cards
spark mostly there'll be it's a fairly
fixed functional form and only certain
things that you can do so in most
applications this will be collaborative
filtering you just have information on
what users did and what items they
interacted with and that's what you put
into your model and that's what comes
out with new electric toolkits and would
be learning you can do much more fun
stuff quite quickly so let's say for
your application the metadata of the
items or the metadata of the users is
very important you can put that in
straightaway and the final advantage is
powerful representation techniques so
let's say any application you know the
visual side of things is very important
so let's say if your Etsy a large part
of how people interact with your items
is what they look like
so something they might want to do is
put features of items which are visual
into your model so you take your classic
factorization model or collaborative
filtering model and their new train is
CNN on your images and you put that in
and hopefully they'll make that
recommendations and this is something
again that deep learning gives you in
your network is giving so in
recommendations these are the things
that you can do you can add site
information again images there's a paper
by Etsy where they look oh can we can we
take the images of our products can we
run and run the CNN on them can we take
those representations and put them into
our recommender system can we make
better recommendations second advantage
is flexible loss functions so mostly
what people do recommendations is well
you know if they user user interact with
an item that's a1 if they didn't that's
a zero that's a classification problem
that's what you do maybe that's not the
best approach maybe that's not the best
approach in general maybe that's not the
best approach for a particular use case
maybe you have both interactions like
the Netflix case of the museum's case
you have both interactions did they
watch the movie but also have ratings
like after watching the movie did they
like it or do they think it sucked so
maybe you want a more flexible loss
function to take take advantage of the
additional information and finally
sequence based representations so
arguably for a lot of recommendation
cases you have a user that performs a
sequence of actions on your website or
in your product
and you want to take advantage of that
sequence information to predict what
they're going to do next right this is
what's interesting they bought these
items in the past was the next thing
that's going to buy and you know they
may have bought books in the past but
they just bought a camera
maybe batteries is what they want or
maybe a memory cannot okay so the plan
for this talk is sort of straightforward
the first is how do you take a classic
matrix factorization model and express
it to a neural network toolkit once
you've done that well you know the
promises past iteration how do you
experiment with a number of ranking
losses and finally well lift sequence
prediction is what you want how do you
switch out the factorization
representation for a sequence based one
so instead of just taking users the
whole representation of everything that
I've done in the past maybe you want to
take the sequence of most recent events
into that count more prominently so as
they go through this this is going to be
FLE this my talk is going to they're
fairly practical bumps I'm going to show
implementations so that sublimity the
complexity but also hopefully will help
to explain and all the examples are
available on github and let me know if
your questions happy to explain and
everything will be done the pie talk
which is probably what people don't have
that much experience with but I found it
to be extremely accessible expressive
and quite pleasant to use okay so I'm
going to start with a classic model the
factorization model who here knows what
the factorization model is for
accommodations they affect quite a lot
of people but I'm going to explain
anyway so in recommendations in
collaborative filtering what you do is
you take information on what people
interact with so we have a set of users
and a set of items and you express it in
this big sparse matrix we've got users
as rows and items as columns and then if
I use interacted with an item that's the
one in your matrix and if they didn't
that's a zero so that's quite big and
that's quite fast and really what you
want to do is factorize this matrix and
to latent representations of users and
latent representations of items so these
are two
the dense matrices that when you take
their product they will hopefully
reproduce the original matrix that you
have accurately busts through
discovering the late instruction of the
problem show you the items that given
user has not interacted with yet but
would be interested to see so this model
was famously introduced during the
Netflix prize contest and is still a
workhorse in huge amount of applications
and originally it was sort of in the
form of ratings people had ratings in
the matrix and you wanted to predict
rating for announcing movie but the more
modern form of it is well actually the
more important piece of information
there is what people watch in the first
place so the implicit fall out of that
problem is something that's used more
often now so a way of expressing this in
neural network form is well you just
take a to embedding layers and embedding
for users and embedding for items and
then you take that when you have a user
and you have an item pair you take you
take the user embedding from the user
embedding layer and you take the item
embedding from the item bedding layer
take the dot products password let's say
for a sigmoid function that's your
prediction so again terminal a is for
users and items connected by a dot
products and in this case fit with
logistic loss so from that matrix that
you have you take it one sim you take
your zeros and you index your embedding
matrices by those indices take your
products and ducts let's go
so in pi torch you might do something
like this so the way you define a
network an pi torch as you define this
class which inherits from n and module
and then you define the DES layers that
are in your model and after that's
finished you then put it to an optimizer
into back propagation so in this case we
just define the embedding dimension
which is the latent dimensions of the
vectors they use then you define two to
embedding layers in this case the scaled
embeddings we want to make sure that we
start the initialization has the right
scale and then maybe you want to have
some biases as well so if an item is
very popular than the bias with high if
a user watches a lot of movies that that
they will have a high bias to sort of
soak up the effect of that and
user so once you've done that you
designed a forward pass so given those
layers what actually happens in your
network so in this case you take the you
make you can express your matrix as
basically pairs pairs of items so if
user one watch two movie one that's a
pair one one and that's what you pass
into your neural network so in this case
let's say this is user IDs is one and
item IDs is one notice of course in
mini-batch index your embeddings by
those by those IDs and then transform
them so reckon you can actually do the
multiplication
you know the multiplication you add the
you are the biases and that's your top
the output of the network so that's
that's effective your prediction you can
pass it through some sort of
non-linearity like a sigmoid perhaps
your prediction so how do you once you
have the network how do you actually fit
it well commonly what you're doing these
sort of problems is you have a an output
vector in this case the output vector
would have for a given user would have a
dimensionality let's say of all the
items that are in your corpus with ones
where they interact with an item of
zeros everywhere else now for
recommender systems this is not an
amazing approach the reason for this is
these problems are very high dimensional
so even in simple cases you will have
tens of thousands of items in bigger
systems like Pinterest or Etsy you'll
have millions of items so you can't
really have this loss function well in
every evaluation you evaluate millions
of the products and then try to compute
a loss from this so what we will do in
recommendations instead is they've use a
sampling approach so you take your
positive pair of user an item and then
you sample randomly a negative item from
all the other items with the implicit
assumption being well this user didn't
interact with this item therefore
they're less likely to like it so we
should treat it as a negative so that's
a sample growth function and we can
express it in part in titles like this
yeah the other display is too far away
I'm just going to walk this
so you you have your you have you users
so these are basically IDS of the users
who has who have positive interactions
in data set then you have the items
which aired the IDS of the things that
interacted with and then you sample
negatives so in this case I'm just going
to say well for every user that I have
in my mini batch I'm just going to
sample a random item that they haven't
looked at and that's going to be
negative so then the objective of the of
the network is to predict one for all
the things that they interacted with but
0 for the things that it didn't so I
have this composite loss what I want to
predict one on the positives and 0 on
the negatives and InTouch compute
compute the losses can catenate this
into one vector this is for a mini buff
so I take a mean and then I can back
propagate in this so we can actually run
it and again all the code isn't get help
so I'm going to use the movie length
100k dataset which is which is a very
famous research data sense but I guess
at this point is sort of a unit test for
a recommender system so if you recommend
the system doesn't work all the movie
lens 100k dataset you have a problem and
should fix it the nice thing about this
is well-known it's easy to get and it
runs very quickly because it's just too
small so in this case we're going to
define a model and we use the point wise
loss but they just described oh yes I
should probably say what the actual
dataset is it says it's a data set of a
hundred thousand interactions between
users and movies and basically you have
you have a 1 in this case if a user
watched a movie in a 0 if they didn't so
we want to we want to fit a model
trainer model get the embeddings and
then at the end when we evaluated we're
going to construct the ranked list of
movies for every item and hopefully the
movies that they have actually seen in
the test set will be at the top of the
rank list and we're going to measure
this with a with the metric called the
mini reciprocal rank which is which is
very simple basically for every for
every ranking that you construct you
take the rank of the true positive items
and take 1 over that so
with the UV ranked a true positive
vitamins 1 it would be 1 over 1 so
that's one if you rank a true positive
item 100 it would run over 100 so the
closer to one the better if it's more
that's about model yes so let's let's
run them on though just defined we have
the point wise loss we put the data
through it with fit and we produce a
skull which in this case is zero point
zero six which is okay but now that we
have this neural network toolkit model
can we actually do better than how we
did can we do it so one way of doing
better is to use ranking losses instead
of classification losses so what we just
run is a classification loss so we have
the representations with the embeddings
and then we have a classification was
predictive one on the positive items and
is zero on the negatives now a ranking
loss is slightly different what ranking
loss does is it says we don't actually
care that we predict one on the
positives and of 0 and negatives all we
care about is that we predict the
positives the scores every predict the
positives should be higher than the
score they predict for magazines and the
way you do it is you construct Triplets
of a user a positive and a negative item
and then say that a positive item should
always be ranked higher than the
negative item so one way of doing this
as this loss right here which is 1 1
minus the sigmoid of the difference
between the positive predicted scoring
the negative predicted score so the
higher positive predicted score is the
smaller the loss the higher your
negative predicted score is the larger
the loss so minimizing the loss ensures
that you never flip the ranking between
the positives and negatives in data
sense so how do we do it with the model
well we use a Siamese Network so we use
the same embedding representation from
the front before we compute the score
for the positive and negative item using
the shared embedding layers and we feed
it into the pairwise loss so graphically
you can think of this sort of like this
you have you have your representation
model for the non positive and you have
the representation model for the sample
negative and you take your IDs you pass
them to the embedding layers to get the
embeddings out you make you take the job
products and then passengers loss it's
called a Siamese Network cause even
though you sort of have two branches of
the model and in principle we could have
different parameters here and here in
this case the parameters are shared so
the actual number of parameters in the
model is exactly the same as we had
before and by the way these sort of
networks often use for metric learning
and some stuff so what might
implementation look like again very
similar to the previous implementation
you sample some negatives but instead of
just concatenating to two lost X's you
feed it into the PP a loss or the loss
for the 1 1 minus Sigma of the
difference between a positive and a
negative Scott so do we actually get a
better result when you run it we do we
run the model with the DP Alice and we
get a slightly higher MRI of 0.08 so
0.06 so that sort of illustrates how
nice and easy it is to expand with
different losses ordinarily if you have
to do this yourself before the advent of
neural network toolkits you just have to
code up the losses yourself and make
sure that the SGD flows nicely and so on
so forth but as here you just define a
different function and the toolkit takes
so of the rest but given that given that
this ranking loss for experts I can we
do even better what we can and it's
called an adaptive ranking goals so what
we do is we have the positives and with
sample set of negatives but then we
sample a couple of couple more negatives
for every positive and then we pick the
one that's closest to violating the
ranking because remember we have a
positive and we have a negative and we
want to make sure the positive ranked
hide in the negatives but if we just
sample the negatives randomly from the
entire data set we may find something
that's actually not very discriminative
so if we sample as a negative and a
movie which is just terrible that's not
going to help us model tear apart what
the user likes more because it doesn't
like so what we can do instead is sample
a couple of negatives and then for the
gradient step pick the one that's
closest to violating the ranking that we
want to induce that gives the model a
better information about what the user
liked
that's an excellent question and that's
possible that's possible so what you
probably wouldn't do is to exhaust it
sampling if you do it if you do it if
you don't do it you get the result that
we just had if you sample everything and
then pick the highest ranked one that is
not known to be positive that is going
to give you a terrible model because
you're going to be just defeating
yourself as you fit the model but if you
do it's the hyper parameter if you do it
just the right amount it gives you a
better result that's true that's yes
there is attention when it comes to this
sure sure and I mean that's that's
definitely a problem and a lot of people
have thought about this I don't know
that there's a good solution for this
yet but it's definitely definitely a
thing there's a there's a extension to
this is if you show if you show people
items and then say what we showed this
item to you and you didn't like it
we'll take that as a negative so then
you know that they have seen it but you
take it as a negative in the fitting of
your model that's not necessarily the
best approach because you may be
interested in you may still be
interested in the item you just didn't
have the attention span maybe to
interact with it and then if we take it
as negative we're just going to be
giving us recommendations later on but
yes that's that's particular so in fact
if we if we look at the implementation
this is very simple and this is why pie
talk is so nice when we actually when we
sample the negatives you just do a loop
sample a couple of negatives and compute
the scores for all of them and then pick
those ones which have the highest
predicted score but I just I have a
hyper parameter here which is hard-coded
which is the rule 5 so we're just sample
5 negatives for every user and pick the
one that that has the highest prediction
score but coming back to your question
is
if we make this higher the performance
of the model actually Falls so I think
this this would be this will be an
example of where you you have a
self-defeating model yes so again this
is a slight variation in the previous
law such as sample some negatives pick
the one that's got the highest predict
it's gone so does it does it help yes it
does help if you pick your hyper
parameters right so in this case we've
got em er our of 0.11 instead of 0.08 so
as we had before on 0.06 so the banking
losses did really do help so a summary
is you have the same representation but
you can very quickly iterate on the
different ranking losses and I just
looked at ranking losses but maybe you
want to include the rating in your loss
as well and then that's super simple
again and then you can see if if that
improves your model all of this is
incredibly simple to implement and you
can you can easily write a loss function
that suits your unique model and that's
something that used to be very hard
now that deep learning has come into its
own it's sort of it's like a windfall
profit to to us who don't maybe need
extremely deep purpose representation
walls so the second thing I want to talk
about is not here but in the next
example I will mention this yeah that's
a good question so the second thing I
wanted to talk about is recommendations
of sequence direction so again maybe
that's the right way of thinking about
this we want to we have a user and all
we know about them is what they've done
in the past this is how we represent
them and maybe we want to encode this
sequential representation or model and
treat the recommendation problem as a
problem of predicting the next element
in the sequence of user actions so there
is a number of way of doing so but in
all consists in representing the user as
a function of the items they've bought
in the past
so the user presentation can be a
pulling representation so we can just
take the users an average or maybe the
sum of all the of the representations of
the items that they interacted with in
the past we we can use a recon general
Network where we actually trying to
capture the sequence structure so they
did something a long time ago and
there's something else and did something
else and what are they going to do now
and maybe you want to use a CNN maybe we
think the sequence structure isn't that
important that maybe if we supply the
CNN window over what they did maybe
there are some things that occur
together that carry more information
than just individual events yes so the
advantages capture sequential
information there may be less pressing
need to retrain like in the model in the
representation model that I described
before every time you get a new action
from a user you need to go back to
training of your model and add the other
action into it and take a gradient steps
and update the parameters in this case
the input to your model is just the
sequence of events so you can just train
the model and then every time user
carries out another action you just
increase you just expand the input
vector into the model you don't have to
do retrain disadvantages well if you
have a complicated model it may be
slower to evaluate if your applications
perform a sensitive Tami numpy that may
not be feasible
another thing is well is it actually
worth paying the cost if data has no
clear sequential structure then there's
really no use of doing and I guess
that's why we're using the movie lens
dataset we'll see if the sequential
structure there is important and again
here we're changing the user
representation all the loss functions
that I talked about before you can take
them as they were and apply them to this
model in the same way so you can sort of
the choice because the flexibility of
the formalization is it's so great you
can you can choose your representation
dependently what you love functions
examples so - to prepare your data for
this sort of model you need to construct
sequences so one way of doing this is
your input matrix could look something
like this so if you have events ABCD you
want to predict from zero ABC - ABCD
where from zero predicts a and from B
you predict from zero a you predict B
and zero a view project zero zero is the
sort of the the null token in your
prediction and this is actually what I'm
going to do here because if we if we run
a return you'll network over this we can
get the outputs of the network and every
time step and then use the output of
that network as the user representation
and use that for predicting the next
item that's actually quite nice one
alternative way of doing this is which i
think is more common because it's more
flexible but it has worse performance is
to split your sequences so if you have a
4 element sequence you split it into
four rows and on the first row you
predict from completely empty sequence
you predict the first element and then
you power you left part and you have the
first element predict the second and so
on so forth and this is more flexible
but then if you're using a recurrent
neural network for every of these rows
you run your recurring neural network
from left to right and then sort of
computing the synced in States over and
over again for this so it's not quite as
it's not as deformed okay
so given this values I'm going to try a
couple of representations so I'm going
to try the popularity representation or
the lack of representation a pulling one
we're just averages users previous
interactions and a recurrent one and see
how fares from the movie lands datasets
so they're pulling representation again
part of it is very similar to what we
did before we have a B we have the
embedding layer a note that we don't
have an embedding layer for the user
anymore because the user representation
is in this case just an average or the
sum of the representations of all the
items they interacted with in the past
so we don't have that anymore
we only have the items and then the
forward passes well you have some item
IDs and item sequences where this is
what the user has interacted with in the
past and this is what you're trying to
predict you get the embeddings and then
you you create a rolling sum in this
case across the sequence so the first
element of your sequence we'll just well
the first element that you did and then
the second one will be the sum of the
two preceding ones and so on so forth
and that would be at every time step the
representation for your user and then
you take the item biases and you do the
dot product so at every step you would
take again like before a dot product
between the representation of the user
and the representation of the item and
that's and then take the sum in that
little product and that's your touch
your prediction the recurring
representation was very similar again
you have the embeddings you have the
biases but this this time you also have
the lsdm layer this is this is based on
a paper that uses gr use but I'm going
to use an LSD M here so we have the item
beddings item biases and LSD m and then
in the forward pass you take the
embeddings
of the items the user has interacted
with in the past and simply run an LSD
game over them and then at every time
steps the representation of the user is
the output of the y lsdm and the last
time step and to get the prediction you
take a dot product of that with the
representation of the item that you
trying to predict and that's your outfit
okay so let's try this on the movie lens
dataset we we import the data in a
slightly different format this time so
that we get the sequences so this is
what R this is what training rows look
like so from this sequence you're trying
to predict this sequence you'll note
those just shifted by one and will stand
with the popularity baseline to know
that we're actually doing anything so
the evaluation here is again m RR where
at every step we want to predict the
next item in the sequence so with the
popularity baseline we get 0.12 if we
move on to pooling we get 0.14 on the
testers and we if we move to LA CMS
which is the best and the most
sophisticated representation here we get
zero point eleven which is which is
worse than the popularity one so there
are a couple of possibilities here did
we set band hyper parameters
maybe the sequence information is not
important or maybe which is probably
most likely I got the model architecture
wrong and doing something completely
different than I thought it will be
doing so to get at this and try to
disambiguate between those we can run a
very simple experiment where we just
have something with very clear sequence
structure and just use number sequences
so the we use we use numbers of the IDS
of the items and then one always follow
zero and two always fours 1 and so on so
forth and run them all along this so if
we do this and we use the popularity
baseline and the terrible performance is
0.07 if we is pulling it slightly better
but if we use lsdm to perform really
really well so at least the model is
fine which is reassuring and it sort of
goes back to the point that well lsdm is
are great if your problem has a
sequential structure but if it doesn't
maybe it's just overhead maybe it's just
cause you don't want to pay
okay so in summary what deep learning
has given recommender systems is amazing
flexibility like if you want to set your
model up differently you can if you want
to use a different like it different
lofts you can if you want to add pieces
of side information it's extremely easy
to talk it will take care of everything
for you second you have powerful
building blocks if you want to use
images well you can use convolutional
representations maybe you have enough
data to be able to fit representations
of your own maybe you can just use a pre
trainer unit and fit this into your
model and will work better and the final
thing is speed of iteration whereas
previously you have to do it all by hand
now it's really really easy really
straightforward and you can you can
think in terms of your normal numpy
operations and mathematics and a new
model will be good for you is everything
perfect
no recommender systems are inherently
very sparse problems you have lots of
users and you have lots of items and
neural network toolkits and neural
network approaches work best with highly
dense problems you'll see nn2 highly
dense problems and recommender systems
implemented neural network toolkits can
be quite slow the reason for this is
well if you have this enormous embedding
matrix for your items which is maybe you
know 10 million long and 128 floats wide
and if you update that entire matrix on
every time step on every gradient
updates and you know when you're fitting
your model that's a lot of overhead
that's going to take a long time a lot
more time than if you implement it the
same thing by hand and use this fast as
you give the problem to your advantage
so there are a couple of solutions to
this I mean you can in certain
frameworks you can use path gradients so
when you're updating the embedding of a
single item you don't have to update all
the parameters embedded layer you just
update that one item but that can still
be quite slow one alternative is well
maybe you can run it on GPU with huge
mini-batches
so in other problems maybe your mini
batches are 64 128 large in this case
well maybe you want to run a mini batch
of 8,000 examples at one time maybe
maybe that's the right way recruiting
sparsity because your parameters s
passed so maybe does enough so if you
run a huge mini batches and that
actually works quite well yes
so I guess to take away pointers they're
very good they're very highly flexible
you can accomplish amazing things with
them but the performance may be a
problem
[Applause]